Trascrizione: Massimo Dragotto
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Un'immagine famosissima,
un'immagine potente
della storia dell'arte,
un'immagine che tutti conoscono.
Ma vi siete mai posti
la domanda principale,
dietro questa immagine
che ha cambiato la Storia?
Un evento, che ha cambiato la Storia?
La domanda vera, unica:
chi ha cucinato l'Ultima Cena?
La risposta? Le donne!
Chi è stato nelle cucine
a preparare quel pasto?
Chi ha lavorato nelle cantine
a servire quel vino?
Chi ha apparecchiato la tavola?
Chi ha lavorato,
perché la Storia accadesse?
Le donne!
Le donne che non siedono a quel tavolo,
che sono invisibili,
che non salgono sul palcoscenico
della storia dell'arte;
eppure la creano,
creano la storia e creano l'arte.
Si dice che dietro
ogni grande uomo c'è una donna;
ma questo, nell'arte,
vale anche per il davanti.
Tutti i grandi pittori artisti
hanno utilizzato le donne
per esprimere la loro vena:
Leonardo, con la Gioconda;
Botticelli, con la Venere;
Picasso, con Dora Maar;
Warhol, con Marylin.
Tutti si sono ispirati alle donne,
e sono stati ispirati dalle donne.
E infatti, chi ha ispirato poeti,
scrittori, artisti, scultori, pittori
sono state le Muse.
Le donne erano sempre
davanti agli uomini che facevano;
ma le donne artiste,
le donne dell'arte, dove sono?
Dove sono le donne della cultura?
Le donne non vogliono più essere Muse!
Nei musei, nelle gallerie
e nelle collezioni
noi abbiamo una predominanza
di arte maschile,
abbiamo una predominanza
del fare maschile, giusto?
Eppure, dal punto di vista dei consumi,
sono le donne quelli che li determinano.
Sono le donne che leggono;
sono le donne che vanno nei musei;
sono le donne che vanno nelle librerie,
vanno nei musei, nelle mostre:
consumano cultura,
lo dicono le statistiche.
Quindi le cifre, dall'altra parte,
sono impietose.
Solo una piccolissima parte
delle mostre, nel mondo,
comprendono opere di donne.
Negli ultimi cinque anni,
soltanto una mostra
è stata quella più vista,
fra tutte le altre realizzate
con artisti uomini:
Yayoi Kusama, 92 anni.
Quindi, l'arte creata dalle donne
vale meno di quella degli uomini;
e abbiamo le cifre.
Per esempio, sulle aste,
soltanto il due percento
delle opere delle donne viene battuta;
e quando le opere vengono vendute,
vengono vendute col 42 percento in meno
delle opere degli uomini.
Le artiste donne sono quotate meno
in quanto donne, punto.
Non perché le opere sono inferiori,
ma perché appartengono
al genere femminile.
E quindi,
mentre meno del 10 percento
delle opere nei musei
sono di artiste donne,
al contrario, l'85 percento
dei nudi sono di donne.
Nel 1980,
un gruppo di attiviste artiste
protestò al Metropolitan Museum of Art
con una performance
che è rimasta nella Storia.
Si vestirono da scimmie,
si misero una maschera di scimmie
per protestare contro il fatto
che le donne erano considerate
semplicemente una massa informe,
un branco.
Si chiamarono le "guerilla girls":
guerrilla, gorilla.
Quindi, si tratta
di un problema culturale;
e i luoghi dell'arte, invece,
plasmano le nostre identità,
il senso di sé e delle nostre possibilità.
Sono importantissimi.
Quindi, dobbiamo applicare l'arte
di bilanciare i generi.
Le cose stanno cambiando, per fortuna;
lentamente, ma stanno cambiando.
E infatti, per esempio,
il Museo di Arte di Baltimora
ha deciso di vendere
quelli che ha definito
i suoi "blue chips",
cioè le opere più importanti,
per comprare esclusivamente
opere di donne.
Pensate allo sforzo
che viene fatto, in questo senso,
all'interno di un museo,
per dimostrare, con uno squilibrio,
che è necessario riequilibrare
la presenza di genere.
Quindi, una chiamata all'azione:
dobbiamo chiamare
all'azione, per cambiare.
È tempo, quindi, di riscrivere le regole;
ed è tempo di ribaltare i ruoli.
Pensate che, 15 giorni fa, è successo
un altro evento straordinario:
questa volta, nel campo dell'etologia.
Nello zoo di Tokyo, per la prima volta
nella storia dell'etologia,
una scimmia femmina
ha preso possesso del branco,
ed è diventata la leader del branco:
una Guerrilla Girl, per l'appunto.
È quindi tempo
di ristabilire l'equilibrio.
E questo spetta alla cultura,
spetta all'arte,
spetta a noi che siamo
consumatori di arte e cultura.
L'arte, e la cultura,
devono riscrivere la Storia
per ritornare, attraverso
lo squilibrio e l'eccesso,
alla simmetria.
Grazie.
(Applausi)